bella tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video sono fa dj oggi domenico e
quindi siamo sue primis ragazze e
ragazzi pensavo una cosa ma c'è siamo
alla ventunesima puntata ciò significa
che per venti episodi di fila io
maltrattato un cazzo di bambino sulla
bicicletta c'è per venti episodi ce se
ci pensate sono tantissimi e direi che
possiamo benissimo continuare anche nel
ventunesimo comunque rai a dire iniziare
ma che se non ci parliamo in chiacchiere
in una maniera assurda
glasspool facciamo questo per iniziare
non so che cos'è ragazzi se riesco cerco
di farlo durare di più questo episodio
perché gli ultimi sono stati abbastanza
corti e brutto stronzo ragazzi sti
livelli non hanno un minimo di senso se
devo essere sincera non lo so yoox
togliti dal mio pene togliti
immediatamente oti piccole dita nel naso
o bambino sul pene ragazzi sono assenso
vabbè comunque scoli questo livello è un
qualcosa di guardabile non c'è neanche
una fine gravity test questo mi sembra
più serio ragazzi devo riuscire a fare
cos'è successo
sto volando con con sti braga voglio la
birra brutti stronzi
dov'è la mia birra lami la birra donna
dammi la birra da mista [ __ ] birra a
tosto distaccarti ti sta bene frutta
[ __ ] comunque ragazzi non ho mai capito
il senso di stordimento agliate
v.madonna che schivata assurda non ho
capito cosa devo fare forse devo dare un
colpo di testa col pallone non lo so a
greg the ball devo prendere la parte
bastarda ferma ferma che non riesco
prese lottista alla doti ralla al muro
apriti brutto stronzo ragazzi come cazzo
fatto non lo so la bestia
sto parlando comunque mi sento superman
non so che senso ha sto livello però
secondo me mi viene da vomitare anche di
brutto dei mig dei macbook pro dogmi
non ho letto un cazzo ma comunque ho
vinto così le news arvine questa questo
mi ispira dei osserva puoi sopravvivere
io sono effettivamente convinto di poter
sopravvivere io compro meno o una nuova
vescica ragazzi gli effetti le viagra
sono sempre più efficaci ma dici di
merda non posso in gran parte possa
risalire in sella cielo troppo grosso
per alzarmi brutto stronzo di un figlio
non mi fai mai vincere
cos'è che cazzo ci è rimasto vivo solo
luke alla fine ho trovato anche un
braccio a bora che affanculo alto
livello impossibile 99,99999 per cento
impossible by steve farci vedere chi sei
spero sia con steam
ok ragazza posso fare chi sono sti tizi
in classifica non lo so ma li batterò
tutti quanti fammi vedere come riesce al
primo tentativo
[ __ ] non ce la posso sono ancora vivo
ci sono ancora viva nonostante io abbia
una freccia nello stomaco non demordo
vai così steve con un braccio solo fai
vedere chi è l'uomo fai vedere chi
sbaglia così
cos'è sto avvitamento amo quest'uomo
perché non molla mai nonostante le
difficoltà e nonostante gli arrivi non e
frecce in faccia anche vendere tano ma
vince lo stesso ragazzi fantastico ma in
film hard check campo minato questo è un
campo minato non è da lì che cazzo di
livello sia devo superare devo superare
le bombe no questo non l'ho mai fatto
cioè non mi pare di aver mai fatto di
valori e janet weiss team ma veramente
tu sei editi confondo scusami nel culo
che cazzo fai cioè vabbè che cazzo tiri
di gli occhi di merda vabbè ragazzi
abbiamo capito che tanto come livello in
pozzi cosa fa
ragazzi già posso fare ragazzi è
impossibile va bestie livelli non li
guardo neanche perché sono una cosa
assurda escape the box pulito pulito con
indiana jones perché mi manca un casino
vai così indiana fai vedere come i libri
questo e proprio classico cioè
quello semplice semplice si fa per dire
sono nuovi stele tano
[Musica]
indiana l'uomo che se ne strafotte va
delle spade nel culo long spy svolge gli
spike vuole lampeggio ragazzi che non li
faccio ci provo lo stesso barbato con
nonno ciak mai fatto in vita mia uno spy
poi con nonno chat ma ci provo
vai nonno che non hai fatto ancora nulla
oggi prenditi utile qualcosa mi dice che
era meglio se ti lasciava poltrire come
un cazzo di bradipo nonno devi fare una
[ __ ] cosa non è difficile c'è sì
penso sia difficile
io dio santo non ci posso credere c'è al
primo tentativo non sono neanche partita
al secondo già vinto è una cosa che non
mi ricapiterà mai più clark beating
cos'è sta roba ragazzi non devo centro
porta pazzesca
raga devo oddio mio santos tasta donna
sta per morire ai game art
ti darò il mio cuore brutta [ __ ]
ragazzi e le donne non sono più gentili
come una volta e testata sta cosa cioè
potete vederlo anche voi che mi lanciano
pure le macchine addosso ma che cazzo è
ormai ragazzi e testato che non cos'è
cioè io ho una persona attenta di essere
gentile si dichiara sipro cosa fa cioè
questa questa donna e super al super
woman cioè non ha senso
vabbè cos'è sta roba super smash up e
che cazzo di senso alto livello di testa
non ho già che pur se ci si mette pure
lui va bene che cos'è che rovescia mio
dio mar la dignosi fa una pippa sta qui
c'è una roba assurda cioè un misto tra
iron man
ronaldinho guarda che cazzo successo il
mio cuore è sempre per the revenge rotta
[ __ ] ti sta bene web un joint 1.0
questo mi piace un casino un nome cos'è
sta roba
se ce la fai sei il migliore nove
livelli devo passare devo passare tutti
a nove livelli multa nate per famiglie e
ragazzi ce la farò sicuro sicuro mio dio
è un casino perché le asce volano c'è
qualcuno mi spiega perchè stessi oggetti
sta volando sono ancora vivo sono ancora
vivo trascinati uomo fai vedere chi sei
ragazzi stanno arrivando pezzi di luke
inaspettate che riavvio per questo
livello deve essere epico
non ci posso credere ce la posso fare me
lo sento me lo sento
noi ce la farò mai più mai più se ci
riproverò 2 miliardi di volte non ce la
farò sono convintissimo ragazzi conti
cazzo livelli avete fatto per me a aiga
vj cioè io io vorrei vorrei capire che
cazzo di nome cosa vuol dire ai capi j
vabbè che fantasia del nome amico mio
fantastico cioè che cazzo di livello
dovrebbe essere questo
[Musica]
rob swing per fa vj greci o ferite
grazie mille
cioè quando leggo sono a me ormai so che
devo cliccare lì perché è una cosa epica
vai favi e vinci grazie mille ce la farò
non ti preoccupare fairy tail era un
allenamento
la posso fare ragazzino porca [ __ ]
non posso deludervi così vai e ti fai
vedere chi stia in tela che è
impossibile suo livello mi devo
rassegnare mi saranno forse sì forse ce
la faccio forse ce la faccio vai così è
di dammi soddisfazione almeno tu non ci
credo non ci voglio credere staccati non
c'è bisogno delle gambe continua senza
ryan che cazzo di tasse ho cliccato ma
ce l'ho fatta cioè non so veramente come
cazzo fatto scendere ferite ti giuro che
a fare i livelli se un fenomeno ma ogni
volta se definisco cristo miracolo cioè
non sono anche se ce la faccio a
centrare il buco si non ci creerà molto
ambigua sta frase comunque va beh non
fate commenti
non ci credo sì sì sì la morte di luca
rallenti la morte di yuto guidare io
cazzo mi stavo chiudendo lo spettacolo
press space press ap che gli occhi
ragazzi che goduria non ci posso credere
anche ammazzato luke almeno dopo sto
livello impossibile cielo un attimo di
godimento bravo io cosi maciullato come
si deve ragazzi ferite sei un genio sei
un [ __ ] genio file e ai livelli che
per farli ci metto 14 anni però sono
fantastici fa vinjay o alla ragazzaccio
l'ultimo livello perché veramente cos'è
giovavi sei un mito continua sbrigati o
morirai me l'hai scritto un po dopo non
credi ci posso fare non so che cos'è
questa roba ma lo userò per conquistare
il mondo se vuoi farci questa roba
ragazzi a premi space barra e dopo
control
che cazzo ragazzi è una croce volante
cioè non ha senso questo è possibile
cazzo è immobile frecce ci riuscirai
raga io non so che che senso al suo
livello non so neanche a che cosa sono
attaccato precisamente bastò per vincere
ce la posso fare
ed i ragazzi non so come ho fatto a
finire sto livello ma ce l'ho fatta
regola rago ragazzi ragù spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto concludo qui
l'episodio come al solito ragazzi se
video è piaciuto lasciato un commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
ogni video trovate nella descrizione
sente con gli scritti iscrivetevi non ci
rivediamo un prossimo video bella
ragazzi